las posibilidades de que sobrevivan aumentarán.
Al inicio de su desarrollo, hicieron una pequeña prueba
con cien pacientes.
Cincuenta pacientes tomaron lorcainide, de esos pacientes murieron 10.
Otros 50 pacientes recibieron un placebo o una píldora de azúcar
con ningún ingrediente activo y sólo uno de ellos murió.
Así que rápidamente consideraron esta droga como un fracaso,
su desarrollo comercial se detuvo y debido a esto,
este ensayo nunca fue publicado.
Lamentablemente, en el transcurso de los siguientes cinco o diez años,
otras compañías tuvieron la misma idea de que los medicamentos
podrían evitar arritmias en personas que han sufrido ataques cardíacos.
Estos medicamentos fueron llevados al mercado. Se recetaron
ampliamente debido a que los ataques al corazón son muy comúnes
y nos tómo tanto tiempo para supiéramos que estos fármacos
también causaron un aumento en la tasa de muerte
que antes de detectar esa señal de seguridad,
más de 100.000 personas murieron innecesariamente en América
por la receta de los fármacos antiarrítmicos.
En 1993,
los investigadores que hicieron ese apresurado estudio en 1980,
publicaron un mea culpa, una disculpa a la comunidad científica,
en la que dijeron: "Cuando realizamos nuestro estudio en 1980,
pensamos que el incremento en la tasa de mortalidad
que se produjo en el grupo de lorcainide fue producto del azar".
El desarrollo de lorcainide se abandonó por razones comerciales
y este estudio nunca fue publicado;
ahora es un buen ejemplo del sesgo en la publicación.
Ese es el término técnico para el fenómeno donde
datos poco halagadores se pierden, no se publican,
desaparecen en acción y dicen que los resultados descritos aquí
"podrían haber brindado una alerta temprana de futuros problemas".
Estas son historias de ciencia básica.
Historias de hace 20 o 30 años.
El entorno de una publicación académica es muy diferente ahora.
Existen revistas como "Trials", la revista de libre acceso,
que publicarán cualquier estudio realizado en seres humanos
independientemente de si tiene un resultado positivo o negativo.
Pero este problema de resultados negativos que se pierden en acción
todavía es muy frecuente. De hecho es tan frecuente
que corta el núcleo de la medicina basada en evidencia.
Esto es un medicamento llamado reboxetine, es una droga
que yo mismo he recetado. Es un antidepresivo.
Yo soy un médico muy nerd, por lo que he leído todos los estudios
sobre este fármaco. Leí un estudio
que demostraba que reboxetine era mejor que el placebo
y leí los otros tres estudios que fueron publicados
que demostraban que reboxetine era tan bueno como cualquier otro antidepresivo
y debido a que este paciente no había tenido buenos resultados con otros antidepresivos,
pensé, bueno, reboxetine es igual de bueno. Habría que probar.
Pero resultó que estaba confundido. En realidad,
se realizaron siete ensayos que comparaban reboxetine
con una píldora placebo. Uno de ellos
fue positivo y fue publicado, pero seis de ellos
fueron negativos y quedaron sin publicar.
Tres ensayos fueron publicados comparando reboxetine
con otros antidepresivos, en los que reboxetine
era igual de bueno, y fueron publicados,
pero se reunió información de el triple de pacientes
que mostraron que reboxetine era peor
que los otros tratamientos y esos ensayos no se publicaron.
Me sentí engañado.
Ahora bien, usted podría decir que es un ejemplo extremadamente inusual
y no quiero ser culpable de la misma clase de
referencias manipuladas y selectivas
de las que estoy acusando a otras personas.
Pero resulta que este fenómeno de sesgo en publicación
ha sido muy bien estudiado.
Así que aquí está un ejemplo sobre cómo abordarlo.
El modelo clásico es: tienes un montón de estudios
que sabes que efectivamente se realizaron y se completaron
y luego buscas si fueron publicados en algún
lugar en la literatura académica. Esto abarcó todos los ensayos
que se realizaron acerca de los antidepresivos
y que se aprobaron en un período de 15 años por la FDA.
Tomaron todas los ensayos que se presentaron a la FDA para su aprobación.
Sin embargo, estos no son todos los ensayos realizados acerca de estos medicamentos,
porque nunca podemos saber si los tenemos,
pero son los que se realizaron para conseguir autorización comercial.
Luego fueron a ver si estos ensayos habían sido publicados
en la literatura académica revisada y esto es lo que encontraron.
Era prácticamente una división de 50-50. La mitad de estos ensayos
fueron positivos, la mitad de ellos fueron negativos, en realidad.
Pero cuando fueron a buscar estos ensayos en la literatura académica revisada,
lo que encontraron fue una imagen muy diferente.
Sólo tres de los ensayos negativos fueron publicados,
pero todos, excepto uno de los ensayos positivos fueron publicados.
Si hojeamos hacia atrás y adelante entre esos dos,
podemos ver la diferencia asombrosa que hubo
entre la realidad y lo que los médicos, pacientes,
miembros de servicios de salud y académicos
pudimos ver en la literatura revisada.
Fuimos engañados y esto es un error sistemático
en el núcleo de la medicina.
De hecho, se han realizado tantos estudios sobre
el sesgo de publicación, más de un centenar, que han sido
reunídos en una crítica sistemática publicada en 2010,
que examinó cada estudio sobre el sesgo de publicación
que pudieron encontrar.
El sesgo de publicación afecta a cada campo de la medicina.
En promedio, cerca de la mitad de todos los ensayos desaparecen en acción
y sabemos que es probable que los resultados positivos se publiquen el doble
que los resultados negativos.
Esto es un cáncer en el núcleo de la medicina basada en evidencia.
Si tiro una moneda 100 veces pero luego
retengo los resultados de la mitad de esas arrojadas,
puedo hacerlo parecer como si tuviera una moneda que siempre cae cara.
Pero eso no significa que tenga una moneda de dos caras.
Eso significaría que yo era un oportunista
y tu un idiota por dejarme salir con la mía. (Risas)
Pero esto es exactamente lo que toleramos a ciegas
en el conjunto de la medicina basada en evidencia.
Para mí, esto es una falta grave en la investigación.
Si he realizado un estudio y retuve
la mitad de los puntos de ese estudio,
me podrías acusar con motivos, esencialmente, de fraude de investigación.
Sin embargo, por alguna razón, si alguien realiza
10 estudios pero sólo publica los cinco que dan el resultado que quieren,
no consideramos que eso sea una falta grave de la investigación.
Cuando esa responsabilidad se difunde entre
toda una red de investigadores, académicos,
patrocinadores de la industria, editores de revistas, por alguna razón
nos parece más aceptable,
pero el efecto en los pacientes es crítico.
Esto está ocurriendo ahora mismo, hoy.
Este es un medicamento llamado Tamiflu. Tamiflu es un fármaco
en el que los gobiernos del mundo han gastado miles de millones
de dólares en almacenamiento
y hemos almacenado Tamiflu en pánico,
con la creencia de que reducirá la tasa de complicaciones de la gripe.
Complicaciones es un eufemismo médico para la neumonía
y la muerte. (Risas)
Cuando los revisores sistemáticos de Cochrane
trataban de reunir todos los datos de todos los
ensayos que se han realizado sobre si Tamiflu realmente hacía esto o no,
descubrieron que varios de esos ensayos no fueron publicados.
Los resultados no estaban disponibles para ellos.
Cuando empezaron a obtener los artículos de esos ensayos por diversos medios
a través de peticiones de la Ley por la Libertad de la Información y
hostigando a diversas organizaciones, lo que encontraron fue inconsistente.
Cuando intentaron conseguir los informes del estudio clínico,
los documentos de 10.000 páginas que tienen
la mejor representación posible de la información,
les dijeron que no se les permitía tenerlos.
Y si quieres leer la correspondencia completa,
las excusas y las explicaciones brindadas por la compañía farmacéutica,
se puede ver en la edición de esta semana
de PLOS Medicine.
Lo más sorprendente de todo esto, para mí,
es que esto no sólo es un problema, no sólo reconocemos
que esto es un problema, pero tuvimos que sufrir correcciones falsas.
Hicimos creer a la gente que este problema fue resuelto.
En primer lugar, tuvimos registros de ensayos y todos dijeron:
Oh, está bien. Pondremos a todos a registrar sus ensayos, anunciarán el protocolo,
dirán lo que van a hacer antes de hacerlo,
y después podremos comprobar y ver si todos los ensayos
que se han realizado y completado fueron publicados.
Pero la gente no se preocupaba en usar esos registros.
Entonces llegó el Comité Internacional de editores de revistas médicas,
y dijeron: Bien, vamos a esperar.
No publicaremos las revistas, no publicaremos ningún ensayo,
a menos que hayan sido registrados antes de comenzar.
Pero no esperaron. En 2008, se realizó un estudio
que mostró que la mitad de todos los ensayos publicados por revistas
editados por miembros del ICMJE
no estaban debidamente registrados y un cuarto de ellos no estaban registrados en absoluto.
Finalmente, se aprobó la Ley de Enmienda de la FDA
hace un par de años, la cual decía que quien realice
un ensayo debe publicar los resultados de esa prueba dentro de un año.
En el BMJ, en la primera edición de enero de 2012
se puede ver un estudio que busca ver si la gente mantiene
esa regla y resulta que sólo uno de cada cinco
lo ha hecho.
Esto es un desastre.
No podemos conocer los verdaderos efectos de los medicamentos
que recetamos si no tenemos acceso
a toda la información.
Y esto no es un problema difícil de solucionar.
Tenemos que forzar a la gente a publicar todos los ensayos
realizados en seres humanos, incluídos los ensayos anteriores,
porque la ley de enmienda de la FDA sólo pide que se publiquen los ensayos realizados después del 2008,
no se en qué mundo vivimos en el que solo
practicamos la medicina en base a ensayos completados en los últimos dos años.
Tenemos que publicar todos los estudios en seres humanos,
incluyendo los ensayos anteriores, para todos los medicamentos en uso
y necesita decirle a todos los que conoces
que esto es un problema y que no se ha resuelto.
Muchas gracias. (Aplausos)
(Aplausos)